hey everybody dog walker here I'm
shooting this just before I go do
another shoots it might be a little
short I apologize but I don't have a ton
to say about this and Rob apologizes he
couldn't be here for this one either but
I think his thoughts and mine are pretty
similar on this and you can check his
Facebook people I know what he thought
of it but this is a Hunger Games
Mockingjay part 1 in this one we have
the furry one that's been keeping up
with the movies Katniss has has been
saved but Peeta is left behind and now
they want to make her the voice of the
rebellion they want to make her this
person that everybody can get around and
they want to put her on posters and make
her this huge icon so that the rebellion
can officially get not only can it get
bigger and stronger but they can
actually win and people need motivation
they need a face to go along with and
she's gonna be the face but she doesn't
want to because of all the stuff we saw
before she's not the best at it she's
not a very good actress so a lot of the
film is pretty much just them trying to
find out how to sell her like how to
sell the icon and make her heroic and a
lot of it is spent underground in the
trenches and there's actually not that
much action in this which is kind of
surprising cuz it's two hours long but
at the same time I'm watching this and
thinking like I can't think of anything
I would cut necessarily um maybe one or
two scenes I punch up with like I'm like
a hint of comedy or something but I mean
it does take it so very seriously and
that's always sort of been it both sort
of the the charm and the horrific nosov
the series is that it does take itself
so seriously you know the violence when
there is violence is still pretty
extreme there's even got almost a
Holocaust style imagery that like I was
kind of moving a little bit my seats
like it's a little uncomfortable uh
which I mean it's I get it and I don't
think it's necessarily directly trying
to address the Holocaust this is what
you go as a visitor old district which
is like you know you see the bodies on
the ground
and stuff I mean we've seen whatever
Terminator and stuff like that is
something about this one did seem
particularly unsettling and maybe it's
just me maybe like nobody else thought
about it but for me it was like really
uncomfortable um but again it's trying
to make you gritty and real it's I I
don't think they're trying to like say
anything or be in bad taste or anything
like that at all I think it's more just
to be thing yeah for some reason just
really made me uncomfortable but it
really sits with her just looking over
these bodies and the impact it has on
her and that's kind of the best way to
sell up the film a lot of it is just
reacting to stuff it's you don't see a
lot of what's going on above it's more
than reacting down below which in most
movies I would find really boring and
I'd be like why are we seeing the action
why are we seeing all this stuff but I
think because the acting it is strong
and for me the fact that they're coming
at again from the angle is one of the
reasons I enjoy these movies they're
coming in from the angle of the
marketing and the power of the marketing
and the power of perception and you see
this in politics you see this movies and
entertainment just all forms of media
it's all about how you market yourself
that is kind of fun that they create a
world where it's like you can kind of
live or die depending on how well you
market yourself where it's not like
entertainment where it's a you can live
or die I don't literally live or die
depending on how well you market
yourself I always liked that about the
film I think it's a fun commentary um if
I did have to pick out any weaknesses I
think a lot of people are probably gonna
be put off by the fact that there's not
much action when the film wrapped up any
people there's like a little bit of
applause and people kind of like yeah
okay it was about I guess what I
expected but I think people wanted
something else like really cheer really
go yeah and they kind of like what the
film is building up you know this giant
marketing ploy and and it's not quite
there and it's if I really had to choose
something kind of wrong with it I say
that the the ending very much I don't
think it cuts up
right time without giving away too much
um there's a point where cuz the last
film cut at just the right moment where
it's like holy I can't wait for the
next one I wasn't even like that
investing in The Hunger Games movie so I
like them fine but you know I wasn't
like oh I can't wait at the end of the
last one I'm like holy what's gonna
happen and with this one it's like that
would've happened if they cut like maybe
five minutes earlier and people probably
know the scene I'm talking about it even
goes black for a second and like I'm
thinking myself and cut but then it
keeps going and it doesn't ruin anything
but the same time I'm thinking like oh
my god why didn't they cut just five
minutes earlier this would have been
like one of the really cool cliffhangers
that will raise a lot of questions uh
but they kept going and it's not bad or
anything but it's just like oh we
could've gotta have that Oh what's going
on scene um so yeah it's kind of my only
major complaint about it the acting is
still really strong it is it is kind of
weird scene Philip Seymour Hoffman be I
mean we all know he's passed on but it's
like I think everyone can uh well since
he's you know since he's dead they're
gonna have to find some way to work
around it but it's like Allison's is the
best CG ever which I don't think it is
uh like they shot a lot with him and
he's in this movie a lot and he's oh
he's man was he good he was so good you
know he just brought a roll that could
have been like anyone could have played
that he just makes it this really unique
you know just well done performance
where you're just with him on every line
and it's never like oh he's acting it's
just here you just totally buy it you
totally believe he's in that scene and
everything he's saying is totally legit
and it's his real thoughts and he's
saying it as he's thinking it up so
that's no great loss but um yeah I'm
trying to think what else the yeah I
mean I think people will probably be
thrown off a bit by their not being too
much action in it but they know one
another film is coming I never read the
book so I don't know what's gonna happen
and it's still very much even though
it's underground it's still very much
about the publicity and the media which
I like and I I like the more people
could realize that the stronger the icon
and the image the stronger the
manipulation the more likely you are to
get what you want which is like just may
have some of these people like you know
we just had the elections recently and
stuff and it's always like oh yeah this
person will lead the way it's like we
got people it's I mean you can pick
whoever I'm not even I you know freaking
out a politician or anything it should
this is all how it works there is no
Savior guys you know it's just not gonna
happen there's just people who are gonna
sort of maybe make it work and people
they're just gonna screw you you know
it's how much do you take of each how
much has the less and the more the idea
is just but that's very much what the
media tries to do they try to make the
big savior and they tried to do the big
that everything is in this person if you
don't do this you will have dire
consequences you know placed upon you so
I like that this film really really
again just shows the power of that and
and how clever you have to be and even
the subtlest little things and the way
they get around it with the Katniss
character how they actually have to take
her to the field in order to get the
reaction that they want so I like that
stuff maybe it's cuz I'm in the media
and I'm in entertainment so I really
like seeing how they market something
even if it's a revolution you know I
like movies like wag the dog and
Canadian bacon stuff I all thought those
are really clever
so this movies right up my alley and I
really enjoyed it
but yeah if you're looking for the
revolution has begun and we're gonna see
lower the rain style battles and they
know if you're like I don't know what
happens in the bugs but I'm assuming if
there's going to be one of those it's
gonna be the next part this is still
just very much behind the shadows and
the marketing and stuff which if you
like that like I do it's great but if
you're looking for the big action movie
it's really not that it's still intense
and it's still suspenseful
it's it's not an action movie I wouldn't
really describe it as that I had
described maybe suspense
you know railer commentary and stuff but
I definitely not actually feel like the
other ones so take that for what it's
worth
hopefully you can come to your own
conclusions about it and yeah that's
about it I'll see you next review
take care